[Music]
so today I'd like to to show you and to
speak about one of the greatest chess
players in the history of chess mahir
Tao because okay I've read a lot of
memories of people which new Tao which
played with Tao and maybe this is like
the only chest pain which all his
contemporaries and colleagues agree that
he was really like something else like a
chess genius
it's well known the tactical head like
the Tao head like a superb tactical
vision but maybe one thing which is not
so well known it he was like like all of
this great chess players they have a lot
of facets of their game so they can do a
lot of things very well so he was
incredibly good in my opinion positional
player and it's not a surprise that in
the late 70s early 80s he won a lot of
games in a pure positional style you can
even look at some of his games like the
famous gain with with Zhukov in which he
sacrificed Knight takes from g7 and
there is this episode quite interesting
in his book in which he describes that
okay he taught for more than 40 minutes
and okay there was an obvious sacrificed
Knight takes to g7 in his opinion and he
tried to calculate everything but okay
there were a lot of very difficult
variation keep some lines that popping
in his mind from one line to the other
so he was messing up moves look after
some time he began to think about one
the kidsong so instead of calculating
lies he was trying you know thinking in
his mind this song so although the
people were thinking that tao was
calculating very hard lines
he will just you know distracted by by
this kid zone and okay after half an
hour so he thought like around 40
minutes or a little bit more finally
okay he get rid of this hair dryer I
don't want to think any more of this
kid song and okay pure it was obvious
cream the disaccharides case to be made
because it's a from an intuitive point
of view it was clearly the best the
decision he made it and want a good game
which now I'll tell you a few more
details and it was of his great pleasure
and in the tomorrow's newspaper Q he
read the tower after careful thinking of
forty minutes he made a well calculated
sacrifice from g7 but the detail of this
game which probably is unknown that if
you look at this game you'll find out
this sacrifice Gideon twirling some kind
of a incredible and matings down oh he
got into an end game with the rook and
Bishop of opposite cars against the rook
and Bishop of Russia curve with next
upon and he won in a incredible
technical style activating his king the
king went towards g7 he was with white
so he had like an incredible technique
tau in my opinion he played a lot of
incredible end games very well so this
was a very strong positional player so
okay in this game with omen let me first
show you the second one so here it's
quite interesting a tau used to play
Bishop b5 in meeting because most of the
past papers taken T if I haven't played
we should be fine but he uses a sharper
continuation which is typical for town
Bishop b5 keeping more tension in the
center so he's likely like in this game
if you want to take me if I let him
develop my knight on e4 which of course
it's not like a line which really gives
white and opening advantage but it keeps
like the type of play which towers need
like active pieces and dynamics he was
like a incredible chess player
so he strived for position which was no
more in Turkey style although like I
told you earlier he can play everything
quite well
so here Knight takes 24 Bishop d7 and
it's interesting is in the second game
now have changed all the choice of his
first game so the second game was like
six years after the first one which
we'll see after and I'll show it very
quickly and you enjoy the tower
positional player which
sometimes you know it's quite
underestimated so night x1d for Bishop
g5 typical Tao very active play f6 can
hockey place an opening line different
from the game which was played six years
here but still without with a pawn
sacrifice so the idea of this is that if
you take on b5 Queen h5 check it is not
win I just keep my initiative now Bishop
e7 c3 still keeping the check on h5 no
take check take 25 well he centralized
the Queen and probably our girl there
will be no ways to continue that the
attack you know in a in some kind of a
complex middle game but you see the Tau
was playing everything very very well so
Queen D 3d takes on c3 and now we have
an endgame which in this moment Black
has an extra pawn it will not be able to
defend it for much amount of time
because he has problems with the pieces
or he has to develop his King side but
still it seems it okay the advantage
will be almost symbolic oh but look at
the technique of Tao just just enjoy the
game before we look at the other in a
better known now very sharp tactical
style so now it be 5 root C 1 and our
tempo Bishop g3 planning Bishop c7 now
we have endgame with a small positional
advantage but at this type of small
long-lasting positional advantage now of
course if you take on b5 in you you
leave me the bishop it can be even more
unpleasant because then you have
problems with the seventh rank we have
pawns on both flanks so it's better just
to keep you know the eco type of minor
pieces if you keep if you take them
different and I take Bishop takes d4 it
can be much more pleasant because we
know that when we have pawns on both
flanks
an open patient the bishop has like a
long range now so take with the pawn a
loop takes from d4 using you know small
tactical little cube you can take the
knight because you know you'll lose the
rook on h8 here and now we have this
endgame
which for Tao you know it was like a
good technical end game which key played
superbly it's not like a lost end game
for black but to maintain the defense
during a long period of time it's very
difficult and woman was not able to
defend this end game so here just to
show how he won the game game
centralizing the king and you see what
was tower technique now of course he is
offering to exchange the rooks because
that the knight end games are very
similar to the pond endings the most
important things because okay the
Knights are the type of minor piece
which cannot win like a temple like the
the bishop so here
the main feature is the active King very
similar like the pawn endings so here
are okay six activity now he can
exchange everything
centralization again and now this night
is much better and now he resigned
because okay he cares I mean he had no
doubt what you happened like for example
if I play 96 our plane 93 and before and
okay the the pawns rolling in even in
the endgame okay quite a nice technique
no and okay I have a lot of example I've
seen a lot of games like that by Tao
so here like a very good and game
technique and he was a very very strong
question or play in my opinion but let's
see this quite famous a game of Tao in
which he tactical vision was quite on on
this play so now queen a5 check 93 and
just look at the game not look at the
many lines which I because okay here
probably like an opening choice a six is
probably better okay it does not matter
so much let's enjoy the game take on d4
also like a natural movie not to develop
now it takes some default we should be
for well maybe Bishop e7 is better but
I'm not going to because there was some
let me show some analysis by by omen in
which I think he was in some points
wrong so just to show you one line so we
should take here and you take I think
this was a line by tau yeah now you're
you're losing here everything no now
even gave a line just to enjoy himself
to mate you see this this is the cycle
because this is like a line by tau so
the guy was really enjoying himself
yeah so visual before castle and now
okay against out this was quite risky in
order to take this pawn but I think it
here it was already a little bit too
late to go back because almond also gave
some lines but I'll show you a little
bit approvals out on a6 take take here
this is a very unpleasant move now you
have very difficulties you know to
develop because the knight is in
is invulnerable on c6 because the rook
is hanging and you're still you know
cannot develop your pieces so on 97 I
think that he gave something something
else here woman for white but this is
very unpleasant I found here of course
you can you can't take with a pawn no
let's just go back you see why I can
take with the pawn because I give you a
check and I give you the smaller tomato
on the last right now Queen d7 28 mate
but if you take with a knight this this
line was given by tau but what I found
aligned by omen the improvement on 96
what he has missed because he has given
this line f4 which also looks quite
unpleasant for black but much more
unpleasant his rook fd1 now if you take
this idea that the point of a from d1
this I like because okay now he can a
clear idea Ruby I check and then to to
pick your exchange now you know although
you know it may seem that you have some
kind of defense no real defense can be
spotted here because you you can you
can't hide you know you can't hide your
rook this is quite an interesting
tactical eternal you can play rook the
eight put eyes to insist I want to play
rugby a game if I play here what do you
think it white will play here to take
away key square so as I see it
f4 Queen h4 g3 and if he goes to have
six then int any then in this line what
we are looking we have like you know
Ruby I take 27 Quincy a troop the
seventh checkmate oh well so we take we
take this squares out of him no not to
be able to to go on them
because then we include you know all
kind of twist like rook d7 and if he
goes to f6 then the line which wins his
rook b8 no rook b8 he takes King e7 when
the queen is on f6 and then we play
Queen c7 Quincy 8th route d7 checkmate
oh so just to get him out of squares no
as I see but we'll be honest he's a
satyr a satyr idea which was shown by by
the computer obviously yeah but okay I
mean when I was looking at the analysis
of woman I saw that so a queen takes on
c3 now we have like the only right here
for example for tau it was natural dry
because okay this justifies you know the
device play basically in my opinion is
the only move here what would you play
here would why because Corey he needs
one more temple to develop the knight
and okay then the pawn is he's a pawn oh
where where he gets put the night here
on one okay not that difficult you know
square I mean if he wants to start to
attack this is like the only mode to
consider I think the other wolf which
happen after humans was the one which he
has seen which was a little bit
difficult but here the first smoke is
natural what well would you put this
night no he put it here 95 okay let's go
good 95 he has to be play it's okay if
he does not accept 96 check it's not
even needed to be looked at it obviously
looks quite bad so let's look at take
when I five know because I he's forcing
you
he's threatening on d6 you know this
check is almost half a made no so you
take here check also here of course
visual physics is the only move yeah
even you even by feeling this this feels
like
position long okay this is just one line
but okay I mean this is like terrible
kf8 leaving the bishop also in my
opinion no need to be calculated I mean
he that he even gives checking and can
give check made me at burg a the fact
that there is a piece hanging and you
have not developed I mean so the only
move Bishop e6 without any doubt now we
follow it Queen d6 because right now we
are threatening quite a few things like
rook d1 and then check on the 8th
checkmate on the 8th
no sacrifice on e6 you always have to
consider so basically in my opinion a6
is only also the only move because okay
let's look at well of course this is
like the the worst you can imagine
though with a checkmate because of the
pin but Knight f6 is also not too
difficult you still can castle and okay
I don't know what you can really do I
mean if you take here you just lose
everything and if you take with a poem
the standard sacrifice this one I mean
here I hear the good thing is you
control the a one square no so you can
play rook d7 and okay the good thing is
that the checkmate is not like in many
other situations
it's a checkmate but he is not a
checkmate no because I Karen them I'm
giving the checkmate on the seventh rank
this is aligned by oh man he gave but
probably when he was looking during the
game here is not very happy but okay
this is like feels like it should be bad
this a six again the same team I mean
mmm
you don't have much of a choice here so
okay let's take here Ruki six the same
no just
so because of that I think that a6 is
obviously the only move you know trying
to get rid of them and here is the the
move which probably my team made the
sacrifice anyone before when he saw this
multi because of the pin that he can
transfer the bishop this is like the
well this is probably here the only idea
which keeps the white initiative going
further on and keeping the attack
because if you start going back like
we've we've seen in the previous example
if you go instead of 95 similar mofo I
mean the initiative is going down no
something like that and it's not a
question that you can get like moves
like that like rube the eight and so on
because I think you can give you back
some material but then you know you have
already sacrificed like a knight so he
can't like this typical defensive
resources like simplification and so on
but away this this move Bishop d2 is
very elegant and it's is difficult to
spot it before you know when when you're
starting to sacrifice like that the idea
because now if you have go to this
pigeon you can find it out of necessity
but to see it beforehand he needs like a
very sharp in my opinion a very trained
tactical superb tactical vision like Tao
so Bishop d2 now this Bishop you know
appears on on b4 you know of course the
Queen cannot go whenever it wants
because okay still the bishop still
stationed on b5 so it has to stay on the
C line because then Bishop takes on g6
out simply be up material no so here
Queen takes on c2 and now Bishop b4 now
if you trying to be greedy like that you
give him the chance to sacrifice back
material and now he has like a rock in
two pieces and now the problem is it you
can attack only on one type of squares
black squares the the light squares are
in complete control of black and this is
not very good so now I'll probably saw
that it if you try something like that
thinking that you are winning he has
like an intermediate
No and it can turn out to be quite you
know in the wrong direction but we
should be for now there are a lot of a
lot of so there are a lot of a lot of
threats here on the dark squares and of
course you still can develop your knife
so here even the the visual picture of
the of the white pieces which are taken
gives a a very good impression because
the the most important detail at these
to this night and these rook still like
you know play the role of audience you
can move the knife because you've got
made only 700 it comes with a price so
you can take my bishop but all the other
pieces are participating in the attack
so based yeah okay this is basically the
only the only move no you have to get
rid of one of the bishop because if not
you get made in a for example okay one
line like this one check and okay this
of course is the triumph of the bishops
no pinning you everywhere so it takes
here check and now in my opinion okay if
you look at this game with a computer
he'll say that okay is the same which
rook you play on d1 but in my opinion
it's much better what key play troop d1
because really the in line is not eat
anymore
and on the a line because the King is
moving on the on the Queen side the
rookin gets on some you know some neat
and it can be useful on de line so this
is like a purely intuitive choice of the
of the rookin it's of course that was
completely right so I like very much
this move although it may not be like
have a great difference but this is like
a really a very good decision with this
room because it feels like the rook on a
one can be sometimes to play a four and
it's really true so here Queen takes 28
ok-hee omen probably quite some point
resign but just to show you one line in
which the rook here can be useful on a
one so just for example okay if you play
like this is a line given by tau okay
you should understand this line by by
the very important agate you can never
take my bishop on before now because you
got made it queen d8 queen d6 checkmate
no this is an important detail okay
basically then you're down material and
still with the problems with the King no
so he gave doubt this line just
depending on your honor okay then I keep
attacking with my with my two rooks and
the Queen but one of the line okay this
is also quite easy line no I mean I have
material but the line which I liked
about the rook on a one is this one
Bishop d6 when the Queen goes me for now
a4 so really the rope you know does
sound job here it's really need you like
for example if you try to keep it close
okay on before I just play here and I
have a lot of threads like you know
Bishop Bishop c5 but if you play b4
still the bishop here is quite well no I
mean the rook I mean on a one so this
was like a complete and inhalation in in
this game but but still he he shot a lot
of a lot of imagination one other game
which probably is not so so famous
gather game I want to show but it's a
very typical of Tao is this very precise
calculation in certain moments when you
know many players would get played
because he got like a pleasant position
advantage would have paid like more
karma just no need you know to put so
much you know precision just you have an
advantage I doubt that Karpov would have
played like Tao in this game but no key
he calculated the line through the end
and he was always you know believe in
his abilities and that's why you know
that the impression is of a typical
tower decision so let me show the second
game which he paid with Hunziker which
was also here from the West
he also a very solid player but in this
game okay tower played very very
skillfully although he kept a lot of
experience in this precise position what
do I mean so this type of position in
the neither was quite familiar although
this is like not the best move rather
now he's known that probably better
first Picasso but okay these were mean
the quite a few years ago so when this
kind of a move balls were not we're not
so familiar with some small subtleties
and so on so this kind of opening line
got famous in the match carp of Palgrave
scheme in which carp on to a very good
game so though he got nothing out of the
opening but still he was better player
than poganski so these two games were
quite famous and okay Tao was quite
familiar he played in a couple of games
he used to work with car before though
some attribute that when I mentioned to
you that in the end of the seventies in
the the early eighties he played a lot
of incredible positional games in a
strict position of time very good they
attributed it okay maybe because he
worked with with Karpov that's why he
caught some features of Carroll I think
that this is not exactly true because he
didn't need it to take something from
Karbo of course the most important thing
mentioned by Carnac he's interviewed the
best feature of working with car was it
you know he took his time just to work
on chess because Karpov working with car
distracted tough from Quezada let's say
other life pleasures because I like he
was like like company like to drink it's
known of Tao so he used this time to
tour work on chess but not that he took
something out of cab because he had so
much talent so he didn't need it you
notice he was just in love in chess he
was a a person which I think if he was
has worked in whatever area he would
have become famous so he was a very
intelligent and very talented person so
here fo Queen c7 a 497
Bishop III Castle King h1 this is the
famous opening line which was played in
the colorful graphic image a5 and here's
to play here rook f e8 but probably the
best is just first to play the rookin c8
just always to be able in order to put
the Queen on PA just not to because ok
what you pay to create sometimes when he
plays Bishop b6 you have to play Queen
d7 still black position from a personal
point of view is very sound and you know
very difficult to get anything going
that's why it was quite incredible the
Caliph on two games but he was just you
know better player and then poganski
the opening has nothing to do but after
that they refined some small details
although like I repeat black question is
very solid it's very difficult to find
some ideas with right here the rook t8
just in case you not to be able on
visual basics always have Queen b8 and
then you play the Knight to d7 so that
the bishop you have to to go back and
then you always have good squares for
your pieces you know 96 Bishop f6 the
bishop can go to e5 you always have to
count to play and the pawn on e4 really
gives you a little bit more space but it
gives a very good square on the knight
on e5 and sometimes can be can be like
with spot in your position now play it
also this picture with white just to
show you and didn't get anything going
on because okay the the black place
Christ tenet I play be super and then I
push away you know this Knight with g6
and I keep good control at the central
squares and I'm keep jumping on the dark
squares
you know because basically it's very
difficult for you to make like a
positive change in the pawn structure so
okay here and Tao after few moves here
he offer to draw because he knew and you
see in this game that when you take on
e6 this means that basically you're
confessing that you've got like
synthetic Talia so this is like a very
good
pawn structure for black I mean they
keep control of the vital
central squares and after that this this
night on only if I fizz like a god I
mean controls everything and you have to
be very careful because it's quite
easier that to take your pawns whether
the pawns on the Queen side well this
one especially on e5 can become a
weakness the pawn on e4 and the main
problem of the patient it is very
restricted knight on c3 when there is a
pawn on e6 the knight on c3 is crying
out loud I mean he has to do like an
incredible job to get somehow into play
which was not able to do it in secret
this game so 94
Ruki 8 now even played in 1 Olympiad
with drink of one of our Grand Master's
Bulgarian he died a long time ago but he
was a very talented player and kidney on
the chief anything in the industry he
just was able to offer draw so Lucas 194
immediately a very natural move and now
what I told you if you if you take 186
think he takes me the pawn this means
that the patient can have only two
results and talk here I think suggested
like to take on c4 but ok I mean already
black has like a good position because
if you take because I control the 5
square I can just play d5 no way you
also have to be careful because I have
like a bishop which you don't have like
the same type of Bishop and some of your
pawns are much more vulnerable so you
have to be quite careful here with with
white you are already after Knight see
for the defensive side but Knight takes
one e6 hopes that ok probably because of
some exchanges I'll be able you know to
keep the position in the limit of a
possible draw so this was one seeker
hope he takes here bishop d4 so now that
the main thing is obviously black has a
presentation but this is difference can
you make out of this presentation like a
point or you know after the game you
complain to some of your colleagues or
friends yeah I cannot dentist but I
didn't play very aware I would happen to
all of us so this is like a very
important detail
he played because the dispersion needed
in the way he to Italy like a very
precise play although it's like I repeat
it's a very pleasant from which one
point of view but the big difference is
can you convert it into a point and he
kept here like a super common precision
you'll see it till the end so Luca fate
bouquet for Quincy 693 oh now it's time
you know to redeploy this night on a
more active position because there is
like a certain strategic element about
this particular power structure the only
example which I've seen in which white
were able somehow to cope with it was an
old game of Miss off with white but but
basically we know that if we have like
pawns on e6 in e5 against the knight on
c3 this Knight is very very restricted
and if you kept like which I've seen
even in some other Sicilians Bishop
against the knight it means that oak I
defend games are bad because the pawns a
week the bishop is complete master the
dark squares and of course you can
imagine that not only the knight is
rejected on c3 but the square d4 is like
a transporting you know a point vote for
the black pieces they go the bishop can
kill the looking girl everything in the
pawn on c2 needs all the time protection
it does not help that the pawn is on a 5
because it's also is a potential
weakness the e4 also can become a
weakness because when something lands on
d4 imagine a bishop well I mean how you
keep your palm so it is like a big
problem so you should not think of
taking on e5 because it means like
strategically a lost position so Knight
g4 logical move rook a1 well I mean
obviously the rook on a 4 can stay
forever because it will be hanging in
many lines and it does not seem to do
much of a job so here to take care of
the last ring and hoping to exchange
some pieces 95 well like I told you here
not even thinking about such a position
because from a static point of view this
should be very bad I mean all kind of
transformation of the piece in my
opinion
with very slight hope to survive
basically clearly because the night of
TV is very very bad piece and it
combines with a lot of vulnerable pawns
in the whites pawn structure so here
Queen h3 well queen history is quite
easy to understand he is trying to get
to some of your weak points in the e6
pawn is a potential target so you have
to think of way how to defend that this
the e6 pawn and not only help defend
because okay this can be done without
too much ever but to defend it and me
know how to be able to progress to
improve your position so now of course
does not like you know to play some
passive moves like Queen d7 so he finds
like the perfect spot for the Queen on
c4 in many of these type structures c4
is very important Square many of the
black pieces in this type of structures
Cillian the Scheveningen structure is
like also like a square in which many
pieces go through the square and attack
in order the Queen side Quincy for rogue
t1 now it's time for the rook you know
to to get into a more active position
and also to liberate you know the Queen
from you know this tax would to defend
all the time the pawn on e6 because I
hate when we play troop d1 he is
defending the bishop on d4 no and when
he depends - Bishop d4
you can imagine it he'll follow it b3
now ask you know how you depend on e6 so
it's time to play concretely and okay
the first move is very natural because
he just threatens mate in one no so with
the temple I redeploy the rook tow to
defend the pawn on e6 and then when the
Queen does not have like a fixed depends
if does now try to to attack your weak
points whether is the info in the center
whether it's a the b2 a5 which you know
and something appears like on c4 so
Bishop g1 covering you know the the
threat truck f1 and still insisting no I
want to play b3 whole cap six he defends
now of course b3
does not help much because I play here
and I still ask you okay what about
the weaknesses in your position so he
preferred Rudie Rudie fallen this is a
very very typical Taos moment so let me
show you yeah Rudy for many players here
will play without any doubt 27 no having
like a pleasant position in a prisioner
taking the pawn on e5 you know a safe
move but very few you play the move
which Tao played because it needs
precise calculation it's not like the
first one you want to play with the
natural human reaction dead that's why
many many players quite rightly thought
that okay Tao is not only a chess genius
but it's like from another planet I mean
his way of playing chess was something
extraordinary I mean his way of
understanding the dynamics of chess
that's why the guy was a chess
phenomenon and everybody knew that that
Tao is something special even Petrosyan
when he was asked once about the chess
pass he said okay there a lot of
incredible chess player but i in during
my life I I knew only one genius this
was Tao and it was not only petrosyan
opinions so here he plays Quincy five
presiding his Tao varakin creatures so
he put the Queen on a pin you have to be
careful where the rupee will go but he
believes it okay this is a good move
because he has calculated that it can be
played so the calculation hold on well
and now you see visually what kind of
calculation it needs it may not be seen
to you very difficult but in my opinion
it's very difficult because it gives up
a pawn with a check then then you have
problems with the last ring but still I
can assure that it was calculated till
the end by by tau which is quite you
know impressive so now okay
you play b4 then I play Queen c7 and now
you know now you have week this is even
deny to c3 he's not defended anymore so
if the Queen will have problems you have
to defend this pawn so he played up the
natural looking and probably in time
trouble okay for hell okay he asked okay
what about you know the last
of 25 but the idea of Tao was this one
Ruka fun
giving the poem with a check and at
first sight seemed that maybe he has
miss a move but the real true does that
all tickle integration missed a subtle
Taos reply which is not obvious at all
but just you know calculated to the end
check here you know defense from the
made it seem like okay you need a lot of
moves we dry to to get to the to the
with black to get to the White King but
he escaped ready is the first one to get
to to the enemy kings and he just plays
calmly Queen is to first gives up the
bishop you know h6 hello okay we see me
tight need I have to take Cooney to and
then I'm turtling group g1 check in and
Queenie one made and you seem that you
have like a couple of checks but if you
look take another look at the boat yeah
you have like one check but not more the
night only 5 controls everything
the the piece on the F line control the
the perpetual check when f5 so basically
you may have like one extra move and a
check what is the end of the move and
this move move h6 probably was missed by
non-scary in the calculation so the DN
twas quite Swift here I take an hour
turtling Luke takes from g1 he was able
to parry one of the threats but after
that there comes this move and now not
able to to parry all the threats now and
now here is I don't know I mean I was
quite impressed by it by the move and by
the move Queen c5 it was you know not
easy to calculate at all not easy but
okay that's why I know this was top well
of course here if a play let's say you
play h3 what do you think that they will
play I can't even move it on the board
you play h3 what is the move that gives
me I guess it probably probably this
move now
and checkmate on g2 yeah all of his
pieces are around the White King which
happened quite often in in the Taos game
so it's not surprised but I want to give
you four for final one game just just to
prove a point because I connected with
you that he was like a fine fish on a
plane in his latest years because in 90
played like a team championship in the
in Russia he was quite eel you know he
was like 54 in a very bad shape okay
the guy always had like a very bad
health he had like a kidney removed in
maybe 69 he can like at least 12
surgical operation he was in a very bad
health and okay around times he looked
much older in his real age but you know
it was tau for example one of the
memories of kramnik was that he played
in in the nineties in some tournament in
Moscow they didn't play in a tournament
but during the rest day the organizers
made like bits in a rapid chess
tournament in the rapid chess he played
with tall towers enjoying his sacrified
one piece another piece and he lost the
game but away he will just you know
encouraging himself but in the bits in
the bliss tournament he finished second
it was like 10 grand masters won
international Mustin Kramnik which was a
feeder master but was very young like
yeah 15 years old he saw a lot and he
remember one liter of kiss blitz the
game with tau so they have half a minute
each of them like a very complex but
seemingly equal position but each one of
them catch 30 seconds he plays a move
Kramnik in his memories and he sees that
there is a very complex and very far
from obvious tactic which many players
even in in classical mode will never
play and okay he says I cannot scene and
immediately tau plays this move but
immediately I mean having 30 seconds and
okay he said we are in a state when we
are doing like the moves with the with
our hands not with our mind
so I see this tactic and immediately
it's played on the boat and he said I
knew this was Tao but still you know to
see this in in one second something
which people will not see even in a
crazier game was you know and he repeats
I knew that in front of me was Tao but
this was another demonstration that okay
even in his final years the guy was but
let me show you from the the same year
when he played to this team Jimmy Jim
he played with smearing one of the the
best chest talents this game was
published in his book one of his
favorites losses so he published two
losses against Kasparov in a guest ow
Soto plating in the already mentioned
style classical traditional because okay
some people you know I'm not familiar
with how great pushing on player he was
and he always looked for you know to
look some idea in some other games and
he was incredibly and creative and
always knew if something was available
maybe you should when you look at the
aim you may not even recognize now
playing here so he was with white and he
played against a young very talented
player and he played against his
favorite Kings Indian so what did he
talk shows in this game for the big
surprise of smearing tower cake he
played detainee fight which was not
expected by him but why I mean he played
this move because just maybe a month
before that he was playing in the some
team champion Israel and he saluted like
in one interesting idea in one game in
this precise line with c6 what's Miran
was playing so the line which he saw the
the new idea was this one castle this ol
was no in here there was a theory with
f4 which you know gives good
compensation for black but in this
particular game
Tao saw and like this idea root d6 a new
move well it was complete surprise for
smearing
so he couldn't react like in the best
way probably Knight a traffic is
interesting also cos parapet with with
canary some years later this pigeon it
was an interesting draw but let me just
show you the game because you
what great positional play was Tao so
hooked actually five probably a mistake
take take 95 now when he played through
key five smearing just missed the next
I'll move which is not like the most
obvious let's say but instead of you
know like it was always with Tao itself
you know trying to to keep the material
although of course okay here trying to
keep the material he'll block your your
rook on f6q play like Bishop e6 inky
threatens King g7 but the move he missed
was a rook d6 now if you don't take the
pawn which you have to do then of course
you have to play with a with the pond on
down no I'll play f3 room before I'm out
with the rook so okay nobody likes to
play an endgame with a clear pawn down
so okay he takes me for
but now the towers idea was to you know
to pin his Bishop here Knight takes one
fo of course the active move now of
course so that if he plays Bishop d3 you
know trying not to give material which
never was like a problem with Tao so if
he so he was never afraid to give up
material if he saw the dish was like the
right pet even was doing either way he
was not convinced it was the right pet
but just to keep you know his openers on
their toes so Bishop d3 just follows
here and then he has b6 Bishop e7 so no
more pin no ok equal material and
probably nothing for right that's right
he sacrifices the bone just to keep you
know this Bishop is as long the penis is
it possible King Beto and of course when
you put pressure on the opening there
follow some mistakes here it was better
to play b6
on which tau I remember some of the
lines which smearing gave were suggest
suggested by tau like rook t1 I think
was tough suggestion in the improvement
because it was a time when still there
were the Yugoslavian
books called informant in which many
players commented their own game of
course now it's long gone so this was
the line which Stargate
still keeping some pressure like this
one not playing for the material but
still keeping you know the black pieces
passive although he probably he has
changes to go change to make a draw but
still you know how activate my Kings to
you you have like a defensive task in
front of you because the rookin games
can be you know I have a more active
rook if i activate my King on the Queen
side you can have problems
he played c5 here probably a decision
mistake and he just missed a very subtle
positional move by town because the only
piece here which is active by black is
the rock on c4 that's right au route c1
he changed the only active black piece
and asked that it was like a plain
sailing by tau of course it was in a
quite impressive endgame technique
let me show us a route c1 rook takes
from c1 probably it was better to play
rugby for but still I agree with meaning
that this type of prision it's very hard
to believe that you'll be able to say
you have two weaknesses on a seven on D
because of the patient of the white king
also will be so yeah you can play this
patient but probably the result would
have been the same and I like how it
happened in the game because now you see
it was like a some kind of a two trunk
so King patient c1 here
h4 blocking you know the the black pawns
in putting more of your pawns on on dark
square how it's written in other
position or chess books here Ruki eight
f6 Bishop d5
well here it becomes evident after these
moves it we may say the typical face
sooner or later it will customer piece
but you know more probably quite sooner
you know this pin will cost black
material so they have to to play or
exchange down or you know without a
piece you know some kind of a quite easy
technical endgame because of this very
you know rookie ages leaves you in in
the case so you can unpin yourself and
okay the rest was pure technique by tau
which are like I told the tower
technique was quite you know
it reminds me a little bit one other
player which is close to style to Tao of
course he is Latvian also the great
Alexei Alexei XI which I was mostly
impressed even from his younger years
not not of kiss attacks which were
incredible but we've seen very good
attacking players but his endgame
technique was what always impressed me
he kept like incredible endgame
technique and this is very I appreciate
it a lot
so here b5 King dito before ok if he
plays Bishop e6 he can even first you
know give this check just you know in
case not not to have any hopes b5 King
III b4 okay now another pawn on dark
square so just in case a3 well he
prepares everything you know just to
control the be four square why because
he wants to put the King on fo and then
he threatens Bishop e6 no and of course
when the pawns are on TAC square when I
win material whether you sacrifice the
rook for for the bishop you know you
can't touch them you can't touch them
because if you have like a rock against
your Bishop you can't touch them if
they're on light on light squares now if
they they're on black square so putting
the pawns on black square here has all
the logic in the world and he of course
it's cast like an additional
easy-to-understand detail I mean when I
put my king when I fight I want you know
rook on b4 check to get out of the pin
when I'm gaining material know so he
takes here although it was you know
without difference if you take a play if
I if I don't see any difference can you
fall and now everything is right a fall
and just a bit of socks one here f3 that
in case here Bishop e6 because okay it's
always you know it's always better to
make just to do to make a play a move
which versus your position because when
you move the King then when I win
material even the pollinator I will be
hanging so you see this great pairs even
one small detail is import
just even the position he's waiting for
for why'd you have to take care if you
can improve it a little bit improve it
till the end when he doesn't get any you
know reasonable moves no so f3 now here
now Bishop e6 take take and ok now you
you lose immediately because he aqui
resign because he's losing another pawn
why don't see 500 on H ok if you look on
c5 it's better just to resign but the
other thing in my opinion is also I mean
I just can go here with the King just
taken C 2 because the rook on c5 also
you know guess the important and
probably is not the only way but okay it
has like this functions even cut away
the the black King know so okay one of
the easiest ways probably is here King
here and just to take on rotation see to
know probably should be should be
winning improbably is not the only way
but to me it seemed like like the
easiest way here maybe they can win
playing also like king of five now
threatening route g7 no I don't see
let's program pool is earth player he
resigned here but let's say if I play
here like I show you here see three play
here I thought this year but okay
probably this is also resigned by years
you know group g7 check now but you know
his son
sometimes this dislike a joke or
sometimes you play in team championship
maybe you don't want any emotion from
your team colleagues this reminds me
like in the book of Karpov when he was
winning against Romania this is a game
commenting in the carp of selected games
he played a very nice game and he has a
completely winning position with the
extra piece I think and he plays like
Queen b7 exchange in the Queen's and the
comment was exactly like we were
discussing he is saying well this is a
move just to let the other team
colleagues be calm just not to expect
any surprises the game is practically
over
so that's right here you can choose this
one all or choose just to go
to take the pawn I probably came at five
is he's enough no I don't see any kind
of threat so you see that the the
positional towels also quite quite
impressive although he got you know
mainly because of his early years by his
incredible tactical vision which was a
little bit out of this world
that's why many suspect that maybe that
was an alien it we don't have we don't
have the confirmation but but we may
have you know a little bit suspicion but
one thing is for sure maybe it was an
alien but he was a true genius and he
was considered like that but all of his
colleagues so I hope you enjoy the great
Mickey Lau and thank you for your
attention
[Music]
you
[Music]